who is this hello Samantha
did you miss me scream six is like
filled with Easter eggs including one
calling back to Jenna Ortega's role as
Wednesday Adams there are plenty of
behind the scenes details for us to
discuss so let's just get into it after
watching the fourth scream we were left
wondering the same thing Kirby dies
right this was left up in the air for a
while but according to this behind the
scenes picture of Hayden Panettiere
hanging out on set for Scream 6 with
Jasmine Savoy Brown we officially have
our answer she gets stabbed but she
lives Hayden stepped away from acting
altogether back in 2018 after struggling
with her mental health I'm so happy that
this is gonna be like my first project
back she loves the characters so much
and she feels it'll make for an easier
transition back into the Limelight for
her I'm excited I'm really excited
Hayden isn't the only actress returning
for Scream Six either Jenna Ortega will
be here too alongside her on-screen
sister Melissa Barrera it would seem
that Jenna's recent work on the Netflix
series Wednesday had a bit of an
influence on Scream 6 too seeing as
co-director Tyler Gillett recently
teased that we might see an Adams Family
reference at some point the only other
thing he'll say for sure is that it
won't appear on the subway but Tyler
feels that so much of what scream is is
that the real world can enter and exit
this really terrifying experience at any
moment plus the fact that the movie
takes place on Halloween makes it easy
to slip in little moments like that too
as of Scream 6 there will only be two
cast members to have appeared in every
movie the first is Courtney Cox
returning yet again to play Gale
weathers ah
just finished filming scream this
actually makes her a bit of a record
breaker in the horror genre as Courtney
Cox officially plays the first female
character to have returned for six back
to back movies and other than her can
you guess who the other returning Legacy
might be that's right it's Roger L
Jackson who has graced us with his
unnervingly gravelly voice as the Ghost
Face Killer in all six movies so far
let's play a game Jasmine Savoy Brown
and Mason Gooding will yet again be
playing twins Mandy and Chad Meeks
Martin from the fifth film and now that
we've discussed everyone who will be
returning let's talk about someone who
won't be Nev Campbell stepped out
because of disagreements over her
contract which is much to the
disappointment of fans and even fellow
scream alumni everywhere this can't be
real news like this has to be fake Tyler
Gillett admitted that not having Sydney
around would affect the script greatly
but he feels that this is a great
opportunity to really dig into this new
crop of characters and to any fans of
Sydney don't worry Jenna Ortega promises
that there's references to Sydney in the
movie and speaking of references Scream
6 has plenty of Easter eggs in honor of
other big names in horror as we said
before the movie takes place on
Halloween and this opened up the
possibility for plenty of background
characters in costume so if you look
closely at the scene on the subway alone
you may notice a few familiar faces such
as the babadook Pinhead and Jason
Voorhees one character can even be seen
wearing Samara weaving's iconic wedding
dress and ammo belt from Ready or Not
which interestingly enough was actually
the role that made Matt battinelli open
and Tyler Gillett decide to cast her in
screen six and a fellow newcomer to the
franchise Josh segarra was especially
impressed by the amount of Easter eggs
the film was able to include claiming
that seeing all the little Easter eggs
helped to make everyone more excited to
be working on it and another fresh face
to the scream franchise is dermont
Mulroney who has been cast to play
detective bayley and if the idea of
having a policeman play a major role
here sounds familiar it should detective
bayley is meant to pay tribute to David
Arquette's character of Dewey Riley who
sadly left the franchise following his
characters demise in Scream five I can't
tell you how happy I am to be even a
role I have in this right and the thing
Dermot likes best about his role was
being able to follow in the footsteps of
the great David Arquette although he's
also pretty thrilled to be added to this
franchise at this time when things are
starting to take a turn for the goryer
more thrilling action dermont Mulroney
isn't the only one promising that scream
6 is going to get bloodier though Jenna
Ortega is too it just gets more and more
gory this sort of ties in with one
controversial aspect of Ghostface which
is that we've never seen him use a gun
before taking up a shotgun in scream 6.
when the coater actor Matt first heard
the idea himself he responded with what
the two feelings of what are we doing
and we have to do that like he didn't
want Scream 6 to feel safe or boring
emphasizing that he wanted Scream 6 to
be fun and to raise eyebrows this
definitely Falls in line with what Jenna
has been saying all along too I think
that this is probably the most
aggressive and violent version of
Ghostface we've ever seen and this ghost
isn't only more violent than any before
he's been doing his research what is
this place
Shrine if you look closely at the items
kept in ghostface's Shrine pretty much
all of them call back to previous screen
films for instance you can see Jill's
blue flannel shirt and Billy loomis's
white T-shirt still stained with blood
and corn syrup mixture corn syrup same
stuff they use for pigs blood and carry
but it isn't only the clothing of
previous ghost-based killers that have
found their way into ghostface's Shrine
you can also see copies of Gail weathers
book on display in a glass case pop
culture is the politics of the 21st
century thank you as well as Dewey's
uniform from his time working with the
Woodsboro police so there's another
reason why Scream 6 has been saying this
isn't like any other ghost face you may
have already noticed that Ghostface has
a slightly different design to his mask
this time around being more cracked and
weathered looking than it has ever
looked before well Tyler Gillett felt
that this new mask was one of those
interesting risks and creative
approaches that they took to this movie
describing it as being meta in a
different way Matt stressed that the
design of the Mask was not an arbitrary
choice but wouldn't give anything else
away for the risk of getting into
spoilers so who would have loved that
ghost face like loves pop music Demi
Lovato wrote the song still alive for
the movie and Jenna Ortega and Melissa
Barrera introduced them to the franchise
in pure scream fashion Demi Lovato
this cheery little featurette was later
interrupted with a jump scare from
Ghostface
Melissa and Demi nearly jumped out of
their skin but fans were impressed to
note how Jenna barely even widened her
eyes maybe she knew that there was a
familiar face inside because when
Ghostface removed his mask it was only
Mason Gooding I just really wanted to
meet you a new ghost face calls for an
entirely new setting too you may have
noticed that we've mentioned the subway
like a couple times now well that's
because Scream 6 takes place in New York
New York baby the carpenter sisters have
come to New York to go to school and
Melissa promises this new setting to be
20 times more mortifying because the
city is so busy that when someone is
screaming for help you'll see that no
one will come to their help despite
taking place in New York the film was
actually filmed out of Montreal Canada
making this the first film in the scream
franchise that was filmed out of the
United States would you like to play a
game Nev Campbell may not be returning
for Scream Six but another fan favorite
has offered to let a TV fall on him if
it means he gets to come back so let's
just get into it head to 25 years later
every year I open the door and there's
Ghostface and they see me and they go ah
can you even make a Scream movie without
nav Campbell she's been the star of
everyone so far but it seems like the
fifth movie may have just been her last
filming that one executive producer
Kevin Williamson actually said that the
movie's purpose had been to connect the
legacy cast members with a new cast
we're a little bit bummed to see her go
feeling a bit
um well just unhappy with the things
that were coming to me but as the
directors of the sixth movie pointed out
it felt like there's an opportunity to
really dig into this new crop of
characters without her so at least have
an ending to the story but that doesn't
mean we won't be seeing any of the
original cast returning for scream 6.
Gail weathers is back but maybe not for
too much longer if you're following
Courtney Cox on Instagram then you you
may have already seen the video that she
posted to say just finish filming scream
but watch out Courtney Ghostface is on
the security camera he breaks in and the
video ends on a gasp that seems to
suggest that Gail may not make it out
alive for a sixth time and it's never
what I want speaking of returning stars
did you know the producers literally
could not find Hayden Panettiere I just
needed a break the last time we saw her
playing Kirby was back in Scream 4 and
although Kevin Williamson wanted to
bring her back right away they were all
left saying where's Kirby Hayden stepped
out of the Limelight five years ago and
with no agent there really wasn't a way
for anyone to get a hold of her it was
only by speaking through her producers
on Nashville that Kevin was able to
bring her back to Woodsboro for screen
six I just want to keep that ball
rolling I have a whole new team of
people ah good old Woodsboro the
fictional small town has served as the
Beating Heart for every film before now
Woodsboro was shot out of California
unless you're talking about Scream 4
where it moved to Michigan Scream 6
plans on taking us away from Woodsboro
and into the big city in New York and
according to Melissa Barrera this
setting is so much more mortifying than
anything we've seen before as she put it
when someone screams in a city where
everyone's kinda doing their own thing
then no one will come to their help the
killer for Scream 6 has done their
research they've been keeping a shrine
with every previous ghost-based costume
labeled with their original owner's name
with so many same looking costumes
standing side by side you'd be forgiven
if you didn't know that Wes Craven
originally wanted ghostface's robes to
be White costume designer Cynthia
Bergstrom hated it and instead suggested
a type of fabric that could be lit so
that it gleamed almost like the glint of
the light hitting a knife this is the
robe we've seen in every movie since are
you scared Anna no ghost-faced costumes
aren't the only ones in the killer
Shrine though if you look closely you
may also recognize a few other outfits
from the first film you can see Stew's
red robe Steve Letterman's jacket and
even Tatum's iconic green turtleneck and
orange shirt as outdated as these Styles
should be by now the first scream still
holds up and that was on purpose the
only Direction Wes Craven gave to
Cynthia Bergstrom was that everything
felt Timeless saying Cynthia you never
know people may be watching this film 25
years from now while West may have
wanted the styles to look Timeless
Courtney Cox had another idea every time
that she came back for a new movie she'd
come with a new look that was just over
the top gross or ugly or too much our
first thought those short bangs from
Scream 3. oh well that was the worst
apparently her hairdresser just started
cutting leaving her thinking well I
don't have a choice now never responded
with not a good release the highest
voice you could go Gail's too much
outfit for Scream 6 will be a bright
blue pantsuit with a pair of green pumps
our fans would be shocked they'd be like
what happened the original cast have
their memories from the set but they
aren't the only ones who grew up with
Scream Melissa Barrera remembers being
too young to watch any of the movies but
seeing her classmates dressed as
Ghostface on Halloween when she was
finally old enough to watch the first
three as a preteen she found them
terrifying but said I think it also like
led me to become a huge horror fan
Jasmine Savoy Brown on the other hand
well well her parents had a bit of a
different approach I wasn't allowed to
watch as a kid wasn't allowed to watch
the old Harry Potter wasn't allowed to
watch the old scream among our younger
cast Jenna Ortega has probably had the
least amount of time to shine she was a
little disappointed by her character in
the fifth movie saying that I only ever
shot with Ghostface and I was only ever
screaming and crying on the floor when
she signed on for the sixth scream
however she was very happy to have the
opportunity to give her character a bit
more of a personality and work closer
with her co-stars that cast and crew
they're my family so now that we've gone
on about everyone who's returning let's
talk about the ones still missed a
deleted scene from Scream 3 would have
made Stu the ultimate villain commanding
his army of ghost faces from prison the
idea was dropped but Matthew Lillard
still hasn't given up hope saying that
he's prepared to set up a public stunt
in which a TV falls on his head to prove
once and for all that stews not gone
speaking of actors waiting for a return
Scream 6 will be the first one without
David Arquette his character Dewey
didn't make it out alive from the fifth
one and David had a hard time saying
goodbye seeing everyone else move on to
work on the 6-1 made him go oh okay and
although he knows that he'll be sitting
out this time he's also made it clear
that he's ready to come back whenever as
he pointed out there is a Coming Back To
Life Element Within These horror films
yeah and this is going to be uh an
interactive circus like you've never
seen okay but for how much everyone
wants back in these movies are not easy
to make Courtney Cox and Nev Campbell
did so many of their own stunts which
was fine in the beginning
I was like that hurt the stunts weren't
only harder for Courtney to do when she
got older but she also felt that she
might have pushed herself too hard in
the first Scream movies saying that she
was definitely paying for it later so
Courtney's most memorable stunt may just
be her chase scene in Scream 2. fleeing
from Ghostface through a sound booth the
scene made great use of close camera
angles and left you wondering if our
main couple was doomed only seconds
after Dewey and Gail finally got over
their differences in fact the scene may
be just so memorable that Jenna Ortega
has hinted at Scream 6 calling back to
it saying there's a lot of that um Chase
sequences including one between Gale and
Ghostface through the lab so if being
chased by Ghostface wasn't enough the
cast on Scream 5 had another way of
getting your heart pumping Mikey Madison
thought it might be funny to scare Dylan
Minnette by hiding behind a bunch of
bags then just jumping around when he
was least expecting it we're like well
welcome Dylan was already dealing with
some trust issues on set apparently
every member of the cast had been given
a slightly different version of the
script so that nobody really knew who
the killer was that'd be weird and
speaking of feelings our main three got
pretty emotional returning for scream
five Nev Campbell cried knowing that
this was the first movie she'd be
filming without Wes but for David it was
more the fact that he was working with
his ex-wife Courtney he cried so much
filming one scene with her that Courtney
said the next day the crew didn't look
at him yikes but David took it in stride
saying I could tell some people aren't
comfortable with that level of emotion
you know there's still extreme love
there and friendship did you know that
Drew Barrymore called the actual police
to the screen set or that there's hidden
sound bites for movies like X and like
what about the fact that there was
supposed to be an entire Trilogy based
around Emma Robert's character Jill well
don't worry I did all the research so
you didn't have to Jason Takes Manhattan
is the eighth installment of the Friday
the 13 franchise and one of my absolute
favorites in the series a maniac trying
to kill us Welcome to New York did you
notice that our first ghost face in
Scream Six Jason was watching it on TV
before the real ghost face calls him up
unfortunately for him that's going to be
the last movie he'll ever see not a bad
choice though truly in the horror genre
a trip to New York City was not an
uncommon plot we got a list of movies
from Paramount that they owned that we
could use in the movie this is scream's
way of giving us a little nod to the
infamous Friday the 13th installment
that brought some of the most iconic
executions and the second we saw that
one we were like oh there it is it all
just fell into place so who else thought
Sarah Michelle Geller's character CeCe
was offed too soon
no mega beta Zeta
also fun fact she shot Scream 2 before
Buffy the Vampire Slayer season two and
because Wes Craven wanted her to cut her
hair for scream her new haircut was
actually written into Buffy anyway I
digress when Tara almost goes upstairs
with Frankie at the Frat party he
innocently asks her if she's part of the
Omega beta Zeta sorority
it was a nice moment that kind of
brought our girl CC back for a minute
but did you catch that when you first
watched it being so into her chosen
character Drew Barrymore accidentally
called the police to set during filming
when she was filming her opening scene
the phone she was using was actually
connected to a landline so during one of
her takes she legit dialed 9-1-1 by
accident and ended up hanging up but
unfortunately the police came to set
Sirens blaring ready to try and help
Casey make it past the first 15 minutes
of the movie Never call 9-1-1 and hang
up they gotta answer that now please
leave a comment if you caught this I'd
be majorly impressed in one of scream
6's more subtle Easter eggs Liza sound
cue from the incredible movie X written
and directed by Ty West and also
starring Jenna Ortega when you hear a
knock at the door of Samantha's
therapist that's actually the sound cue
from the movie X it's actually a cool
little nod from the directors as they're
both friends with tie West because they
all work together on the horror movie
VHS from 2012. it really is a small
world in the horror genre so this
shouldn't come as a total shock as
directors love to make little cameos in
their films even Wes Craven showed up in
the first Scream movie The Scream 6
directors Matt battinelli open and Tyler
Gillett show up in the movie wearing
Halloween costumes Matt's dressed up as
Kurt Cobain and Tyler has a fake knife
stuck in his head my friends who else's
favorite Ghostface was scream 4's Jill
what world are you living in I don't
need friends did you know that it was
going to be the start of another Trilogy
when Wes Craven started talking to the
writer Kevin Williamson about going back
to Woodsboro he didn't want it to just
be for a one-off he wanted to do a whole
new ghost face Trilogy with Emma Roberts
in the original Scream 4 Jill's fate was
supposed to be left uncertain with the
Cliffhanger to be resolved in the next
installment unfortunately though Wes
Craven passed away in 2015 and Kevin
Williamson didn't want to create an
entire Trilogy without him did you
notice this callback in Scream 5 when
Sam is on the phone with Ghostface she
in a fit of rage demands for him to come
and get her come and get me with
pleasure Sydney Prescott has that exact
experience with her ghost face in Scream
too she also demands the killer to come
and get her then why don't you show your
face you coward to which Ghost Face
responds my pleasure we almost didn't
get him on the series at all he actually
turned down the screen project not once
but twice in the 90s Wes Craven was
known for his horror genre movies
because of a Nightmare on Elm Street and
The Hills Have Eyes so obviously he was
a Top Choice for the director when
scream was being considered for
production among other names like
Quentin Tarantino at that time though
Wes Craven wanted to take a break from
all things Gore so he ended up turning
the project down because he thought it
was way too violent and like obviously
though after rejecting the movie twice
he did end up coming around how do you
think the series would have turned out
without him so I already mentioned how
Wes Craven made an appearance in the
first film he showed up as the janitor
Fred obviously wearing a Freddy Krueger
sweater because well duh there's also a
direct reference to The Nightmare on Elm
Street movies more so how the sequels
all sucked and aside from this there are
a ton of other Wes Craven references
scattered throughout the film even in
Scream 6 you can spot hundreds of Wes
Craven costumes in the first film Tatum
mentions Wes Carpenter movies which is a
combination of Wes Craven and John
Carpenter starting to sound like some
West Carpenter flickers the director of
the 1978 Halloween movie there's also a
Freddy Krueger sweater hanging on the
door and scream too a poster for The
Hills Have Eyes and a trivia question
about Freddy in Scream 4. Freddy Krueger
uh raise your hand like I could go on
but this video would be hours long so
what are some other Wes Craven
references you picked up on it wasn't
until Kevin Williamson met the writers
and directors for Scream 5 that he felt
comfortable continuing the project they
even paid a heartfelt tribute to Wes
Craven on screen Dylan Minnette plays
the character Wes Hicks and in Scream 5
in which they describe his brutal end as
the ultimate tribute for Wes Craven it's
holy drawn out and filled with red
herrings all the way until his gory
demise in the film students host a
memorial for Wes which doubles as an
on-screen memorial for Wes Craven when
the kids toast to West
the voices of all the cast and crew from
the previous movies were layered in as a
way for them to pay tribute to the
iconic director also known as our
favorite Leading Lady Drew Barrymore did
you know that she was actually supposed
to play Sidney Prescott but she chose to
play Casey Instead at the time having
your biggest star and face of the film
offed within the first 15 minutes was
absolutely unheard of well we can thank
Drew Barrymore for that shocking twist
she talked about this decision with Sean
Evans in 2020. in the horror film genre
my biggest pet peeve was that I always
knew the main character was going to be
slugging through at the end but was
going to Creak by and make it what I
wanted to do is take that comfort zone
away so I asked if I could be Casey
Becker so that we would establish that
the rule does not apply in this film did
you know Ghostface Works two jobs it's
funny because Courtney Cox is often
pointed out to be the only character who
has been with the entire franchise since
the very beginning but that's not true
Roger L Jackson the voice of Ghostface
has also been with the franchise since
the very beginning
I like that thing you're doing with your
voice Randy this whole time I thought it
was an actual voice changer correct
Amber might live to see the sunrise nope
it's just one talented guy can you
handle that
Monday something else that's pretty
hilarious too is that he also does the
voice of Mojo Jojo from The Powerpuff
Girls Do not continue with the ramblings
well my ramblings other emblems will be
obey it's so clear why they did this
Halloween Trope there are so many
references within all of the costumes
more than I could ever possibly list on
this one video as a nod to Roger there's
one person dressed as Mojo Jojo in the
subway station oh come on now
so I could go on and on about the scream
world and all its clever references and
Easter eggs hidden in each scene but
I'll spare you my ramblings just this
once we share a certain history what's
your favorite Easter egg and what do you
think should have been included in the
list
foreign